all right the next stop is Manish
additional from yourself about 20 models
in sparse recoveries Thanks
so what this talk is going to be about
is an algorithm for this problem of
sparse recovery and its connection with
an algorithm that is found in nature in
particular something that slime molds
used to find food so let me start with
the problem of sparse recovery which is
the following you're given a bunch of
equations over variables the number of
equations is think of it as
significantly less than the number of
variables so here you have three
equations in four variables so such
system of equations have typically
infinitely many solutions if they have
one and one of the heuristics which
people use to find find a solution or
pick a solution from this infinite space
of solutions is to find one which is the
sparse test and this this this problem
finds applications in a wide variety of
areas in in science and engineering I
guess many of you have at some point or
the other encountered this a bit more
formally given a matrix a which is an N
cross n matrix and a vector B the goal
is to find a vector in this in this
space ax equal to B with minimum l0 norm
this problem turns out to be np-hard
and hence one approach to tackle it is
to look for relaxations the first flak
session that comes to the mind and I
mean admitting the fact that the
hardness comes from the zero or the
sparsity norm is to relax it to the two
norm and here the problem really becomes
the following that if you given this
subspace ax equal to B find the largest
l2 ball centered around the origin which
touches this subspace so that's the
problem
finding the solution to this is easy we
saw it and an examiner's talked as well
that this is just solving a linear
system of equations so that's good
however if your goal is to find a sparse
point in this subspace then it is
unlikely and the reason is the strong
convexity of the l2 ball so one way you
might want to deal with it is to instead
of looking for the l2 ball you look at
the l1 ball so now we try to find a
solution try to find a point on this
subspace which touches the largest
element ball so do the same experiment
at the origin start growing in l1 ball
until it touches your subspace and at
least from this picture which is in two
dimensions you get some idea that maybe
this is a better thing to do if you're
looking for solutions which are more you
know more sparse and indeed this this
intuition was made precise by a large
body and work of by many influential
people Donahoe Kanda's Romberg and Terry
Tao who proved that the solution to this
optimization problem which is an l1
optimization problem over a subspace
does indeed find this partial solution
under what is called the districted
isoparametric property this is some
property on the matrix a with guarantees
that if you solve this l1 minimization
problem you find this Parsis solution in
the subspace as well so it's not really
relaxation it captures the problem
exactly the nice thing about this is
that this is computationally feasible at
least in principle this corresponds to
solving some kind of a linear program
however in practice people prefer to use
a very simple iterative algorithm for it
which is called the iteratively
re-weighted nice squares method despite
the fact that the problem can be solved
using a linear program there is a there
is a there is an iterative method which
which relies on this observation I
mentioned in the previous slide that l2
minimization is computationally very
compared to L one minimization or a
subspace so let's try to do the
following let's reduce the L 1
minimization problem to a sequence of L
2 minimization problems in the in the
following very precise sense
so the algorithm maintains or construct
a sequence of points by starting from a
point by 0 on the subspace to y1 and
from YK 2 YK plus 1 how does it do it is
is the following simple equation it
solves the least square problem except
that it picks the weights of each
coordinate as the absolute value of the
Y coordinates it has from the previous
iteration and so what might be the
intuition for this well roughly if for
some I you have only is close to zero or
even zero then the way it becomes really
large and so you would not put nonzero
weight on this point unless you really
have to do it so in in particularly this
is really zero then the weight is
infinity and so you will never put any
so once once a coordinate becomes small
it tends to remain small but that's
that's a guiding heuristic I think the
main thing to note about this algorithm
it is really simple it's it's so simple
it has really a two line MATLAB code and
here is the rendering of it which you
can see how it actually computes the
solutions at every point it just grows
this ll two ball or an ellipsoid until
it hits the space and that's the new
point so it's a simple robust and
distributed heuristic the question is
does it converge or if and when if and
when it converges and if so what is the
time complexity of this so the problem
is that as defined this this method can
actually get stuck so you can construct
examples of subspaces as along with
starting points which get trapped in
certain suboptimal points and can never
escape from there
another obstacle to analyzing the
convergence of it is the fact that each
vertex of each each each word so as I
said that this is this correspond to
some kind of an l1 minimization problem
and each vertex of that problem
essentially acts like a local a local
attractor in certain directions or in
some sense a saddle point and which
might mean that you might have to go
along every vertex before you reach or
find find the optimal point so in in in
in in some related work by ingrid
daubechies and her quarters and more
recently by back they considered a
modification of this IR LS rule where
they add some small noise parameter in
the denominator and give some results
about the convergence of these dynamics
with good starting points however the
problem that they solve is slightly
different than finding the l1
minimization l1 minimal point over the
subspace okay so what do we prove we
prove two things the first which I find
quite interesting is that this algorithm
which is quite popular turns out to be
essentially identical to an algorithm
that we found in nature and the second
offer of a result is that we use this
equivalence along with the analysis of
this natural algorithm of rigorous
analysis of this natural algorithm to be
able to give an analysis for this ILS
method so concretely we show that if you
want to get within 1 plus epsilon
multiplicative of the optimal solution
the convergence is in time which depends
on one over epsilon cube yes
it's all with using linear programming
so it's yeah this is this is a deep and
philosophical question I prefer to take
it offline I think that the point is so
why people prefer to use I or less
versus when you have linear programming
solvers I think its first of all it's
simple I think there are also robustness
properties of these algorithms which are
probably observed in practice and also
they are very you can have massively
distributed algorithms for these so this
is my my guess I'm not a practitioner in
iron less so I can't really comment but
I think the fact that essentially a
similar net algorithm is found in nature
seems to suggest that perhaps time
complexity is not the only measure that
we should treat an algorithm with this
is one measure for sure and probably
crucial for many many applications but
there may be other important aspects to
an algorithm so okay you know CFA is not
the condition number it is some number
which depends on a and I will comment a
comment on it in a second so I think
let's look at an application of or what
is a special case of this l1
minimization problem in fact it's this
undirected min-cost flow problem where
you are given a graph and imagine you're
given a source and sink and your goal is
to ship as much flow as possible from
the source to a sink while minimizing
the sum of the absolute values of the
flows so this problem this problem
actually can capture things like
bipartite matching and even capacitated
min-cost flow and so on so it can
capture many many combinatorial problems
and so what does IRL s well i RLS
applies because it's exactly in the
setting of finding the l1 minimizing
vector in a subspace so what does it
correspond to it really corresponds to
the following
following following algorithm that what
you do is you maintain resistances for
edges and these resistances are
precisely described by this quantity so
if your current solution if your current
flow candidate was ye of K then you you
you you compute and the new vector Y is
really just the electrical flow
corresponding to the demand B when we
replace each edge with a resistor of
value 1 over ye of K okay so these are
algorithms which slowly play with the
resistances of the edges and compute
flows in graphs and what our result
gives us for this problem is an
algorithm this runs in time m n over
epsilon cube there is nothing hiding now
here except maybe some log factors in M
this M comes from the fact that every
step of it which is solving a laplacian
system or computing an electrical flow
can be done in or tilde m time and this
n is this quantity that I mentioned in
the previous slide in this setting so
the fact that these matrices are totally
uni modular implies that this number is
n in general it depends upon the maximum
sub determinant of this matrix P so I
guess one thing to note is that if you
look at the history of the recent
breakthroughs in in computing max flows
in graphs they all essentially use some
variant of this idea that you you view
the graph as an electrical Network there
is some way to adjust the resistances
iteratively based on the current flow
and
[Music]
and end up computing combinatorial flows
and graphs okay
so this was this was just a short
interlude let's go go to this second
character in the talk which is this
algorithm and how it makes an appearance
in nature so here I'll show you a quick
video for those of you who have not seen
it so what you see here is this organism
which is called the slime mold and the
in this experiment what has happened is
that initially the slime mold was placed
over the entire maze and then food was a
little bit fast and then food displays
that to sources in this maze at the two
endpoints of the maze and the organism
by essentially doing something along
these segments changes its itself it
reorganizes in the maze and finds the
shortest paths connecting the two food
sources in this maze ok so this is an
experiment which was done around 2000 or
early - I think night late 90s and early
2000 it got a lot of attention from both
media and and even in TVs there were TV
shows about slime molds how does it do
it so so the the the the remarkable
engineering that nature has provided it
is the following which allows it to do
so you can think of each of these
segments in the maze that the slime mold
is corresponding to a tube in which some
liquid is flowing through and you can
see this in the video as well that
something is flowing through these
tubular structures which are connected
inside the maze and the the and the fact
is that depending upon the flux of the
flow through each of these tubes it has
this ability to control the diameter and
a bit more precisely
if the flow is or if the flux is large
compared to the current diameter then
the diameter increases in the next time
step and if the flux is small compared
to the recurrent diameter then the
diameter decreases and this gives rise
to the following mathematical model
which was used to describe its dynamics
if Sigma is so Sigma is a vector which
corresponds to for every edge you have
the diameter there so D Sigma by DT
which is how the tubes are changing in
in their diameter is equal to the
magnitude of the flux minus the current
diameters this is a coordinate wise
equation of a couple set of differential
equations they're coupled because the
flow or the flux Phi depends on all the
diameters okay so this is a differential
equation and you mask how the flux is
computed well you can you can argue
using simple fluid dynamics that if you
fix the diameters to Sigma eyes then the
flux is nothing but a least square
problem which is the following so you
can arrive at this from completely
physics considerations that this is what
happens you ask what is the subspace ax
equal to B I guess in this case is the
incidence matrix of the maze where the
two food sources are labeled s 1 and s 2
and you can arbitrarily pick one and say
that is plus 1 and the other two be
minus 1 so you can view the slime mold
in a maze as a collection of
interconnected tubes whose diameter
changes with time and it was proved by
Bonifacio and others building up on some
prior work that this dynamical system
always converges to a shortest path in a
maze
so cool fact I think a nice nice
observation about nature so first result
it establishes that this I are less and
the slime mole are essentially the same
algorithm requires a little bit more ice
it's not entirely obvious what the
correspondence is well it's clear that
there is some connection because both of
them seem to be solving in every
iteration or at leat every time step
some kind of least square problem what
is not clear is what is the
correspondence between the the diameters
and these vive area bills which
correspond to flow so it turns out that
the way to view that the first thing we
need to do is to fix time because in one
case time is discrete and in the other
case time is continuous so we introduce
a parameter H which you can think of as
a discrete something which is between
zero and one zero means continuous time
and one means discrete time and then we
introduced two sets of variables instead
of so both of these dynamical systems
have one set of variables so we
introduced two sets of variables one
corresponding to each of them
and I consider the following algorithm
which we call the meta algorithm so you
have the Y variables and the W variables
so think of W variables as the victor
area below are these Sigma variables and
the update is the following so at with
respect to the weights W you find the
least square solution in this subspace
ax equal to B and then you do the
following you compute the new point Y
prime as a convex combination of the old
point Plus this flow vector that you
have computed so remember that this
flank vector flow vector Q could have
both positive or negative entries while
so we have to be careful how we are
built of it so the
rates are updated by the absolute value
of this vector q so weights always
remain positive because you start off
with some positive weight so you're
always positive the vector Y can be both
positive or negative and now it's kind
of once you see this algorithm you can
see that a projection of of this Metta
algorithm onto the W variables gives you
exactly the the Phi's area more the
slime mold dynamics and the projection
of this dynamical system on to the Y
variables gives you the IRL s so we have
this dynamical system which consists of
twice as many variables and it projects
in two different regimes to these two so
this is how they are connected with each
other and in fact our analysis goes from
here to there so it starts off with some
analysis for the Phi's areum dynamics
and ends up actually proving convergence
or running time for the meta algorithm
which then implies the convergence of
the ILS method or rather a damped
version of the tireless method okay so a
few words about the convergence so
remember these are our update rules in
our algorithms we always maintain that
we are in the subspace so for all KS a
YK is equal to B in addition you can
check that the algorithm also maintains
the following property that if you start
with a vector W 0 and y 0 so that W 0
dominates in absolute value y 0 then
this will always be true and our goal is
the following that if I start with the
point y 0 whose whose value in l1 norm
is at most M times the value of the
optimal solution in how many iterations
can we get within 1 plus epsilon of the
optimal solution so we want to
understand the number of iterations
required to do that
and the key thing here is to come up
with potential functions that's really
where the essence lies so how to analyze
or how to track progress of such a
dynamical system and this is where the
inspiration from the analysis of slime
mold dynamics comes in there are three
natural potential functions which I can
talk more about but I'll just tell you
what these functions are so the first
function is the cost function so this is
the sum of widths of all the tubes that
the slime mold is using at time k then
there is a natural quantity called the
energy so this is so this is exactly the
flux or the total energy consumed by
this physical system at time k and
finally there's this entropy like
quantity the glory Enzo mentioned
something here about generalized entropy
it's exactly it's exactly the Bregman
divergence with respect to that for
those of who you know for those of you
don't know here is a formula for the the
entropy difference between the optimal
point and the current weight vector so
these are the three potential functions
which are sufficient to explain the
convergence of of this dynamical system
and I'm not going to give you an
elaborate proof the proof is not
difficult it's a few pages of
calculations once you realize what is
there to be proved and once you have the
right potential functions so here is a
cartoon version of what are the two
cases that show up in the analysis in
the first case we are in a position
where at time at time K 1 there is a
large gap between cost and energy and
here we can prove that in the
immediately following time step the cost
of the solution drops a lot and ii ii ii
cases when the energy and cost are close
to each other so the difficulty is that
even though they are close to each other
they could be quite far from the optimal
work value or the optimal cost and here
surprisingly the dynamics of the slime
mold are designed so that one can prove
that if it is indeed the case that
energy and cost are close to each other
and they're both far away from the
optimal cost then in the next step the
system reorganizes itself in this
information space and you can get a
reduction in this entropy potential
function so this these are the two cases
let me tell you that the two things that
you need to prove the first one in the
first case all we need to all we need to
use is the fact that the the vector Q is
this optimal vector in the sense of
least square so the vector that
minimizes the least squares with respect
to the current beit's the second step is
actually more interesting and it also
ties up with the notion of width that
lorenzo was talking about so one can
prove that if I pick H to be epsilon
over this quantity here
okay so this is a mysterious looking
quantity but nevertheless if I can prove
that H is if I pick H to be
approximately this then I see a drop in
entropy and this has something to do
with the log function and so on I'm not
going to explain the question is how big
can this number be how big can this
quantity be so so so this is a notation
where for a vector X we are using
capital X as a diagonal of this it turns
out that you can you can you can come up
with some bounds for this number
depending upon the the maximum sub
determinant of this matrix a and that's
where if it's a flow like problem then
the maximum sub determinant is 1 and so
you can get good bounds okay so this is
all I'm gonna talk about this connection
let me tell you another dynamical system
which was inspired by looking at the
slime mold dynamics it's a bit different
however it's geared towards proving the
general linear program the general
linear program is the following that
your goal is to minimize summation X I
you could have cost here it doesn't
really matter where X is non-negative
and Ito I and others in zoo and
johansson gave the following dynamical
system for computing solutions to this
linear program so what is the difference
between this dynamical system and the
previous one the difference is that
there is no absolute value here so this
number can be both positive and negative
and it doesn't really it doesn't really
[Music]
so this negativity can be a big problem
here and here they asked this question
about whether a solution exists for all
x and if it does then what is the
convergence and complexity and more
importantly what could this option
what could this you know what could this
dynamical system being optimizing so in
a related work we answer some of these
questions the first one is about an
optimization viewpoint so what exactly
is happening so how to think of this
dynamical system the observation is that
this corresponds to a flow on a Romanian
manifold and the Romanian a manifold
that shows up is the following that it
consists of all points which are
strictly positive and satisfy ax equal
to B and the metric at the point X is
the diagonal inverse so if you are at a
point X 1 X 2 then the metric is 1 over
X 1 and 1 over X 2 at that point and
this defines is following inner product
on the tangent space and now you can
show that if you compute the gradient of
the cost function with respect to this
metric then you get exactly this update
so one has to change the geometry of
this of this problem to understand this
as some kind of a gradient flow that's
what we did you may ask what is this X
inverse I mean and where does it arise
from there is a very simple answer to it
and that is the entropy function so if
you look at if you look at if you start
with an entropy function H of X which is
summation X I log X I and you look at
the scale divergence between them
between two points and you let that and
you can compute the KL divergence of two
points which are getting closer and
closer to each other you get exactly
this Romanian metric out of this these
are all like this is a well-known fact
so nothing here is really not known to
the experts just putting these things
together is what we realized and what
this gives us this optimization new
point gives us is a reaper amat relation
of this of this dynamical system as an
interior point method with an entropy
light barrier so imagine that you start
off with some point in the domain Omega
and consider the following consider the
following optimization problem where
there is a parameter mu which is
something which is bigger than zero so
this was your cost function and this is
kind of like a regularizer
and azmuth's going to infinity the
effect of the regularization is going to
get lesser and lesser and so simple fact
here is that as if I let nu to infinity
then the solution to this this program
tends to the optimal solution
and what we can prove is that this
parametric solution X mu as a function
of mu satisfies the same differential
equation that I showed you in the
previous previous slide if I do a change
of variables between mu and T so in some
sense so in the previous slide I showed
you how this the vivarium dynamics the
directed by cerium dynamics correspond
to a walk on a Romanian manifold here
you can see there's a parametric
solution to convex up a convex
optimization problem and this also gives
a very easy proof of existence of the
solution at all times and interestingly
one can from this derive a rate of
convergence for the directed min-cost
flow problem which depends something
like log 1 over epsilon so this method
this this this method it's not clear
where it lies whether it is closer to
car markers projective scaling or to the
affine scaling it seems like it's
somewhere in between because we're
affine scaling you don't expect such a
convergence but it's clearly not
projective scaling as well there are
some subtle differences and it's I think
an interesting problem to understand
when this algorithm can be made to be
fast when you discretize it ok so I'll
conclude so in this talk we saw some
dynamics which are inspired by looking
at slime molds and some connections to
vary to do some algorithms which are at
the center of many of the recent
developments and also some of the old
work in math programming literature such
as the IRL s interior point methods and
Network flow algorithms arising from
electrical flows all of these algorithms
turn out to be very simple
experimentally robust very nice
distributed implementations and also
proved a part of our work is to prove
that they're correct and establish some
preliminary complexity bounds the main
question that remains for the for the
experts here is to try to see how fast
you can make these methods so just like
in the case of electrical flows by
changing or coming up with more clever
and clever ways to use electrical flows
or how to update resistances I'm hoping
that some of these methods can also
inspire such results for directed
directed flows and also prove some
improved bounds on the method of IR les
itself this I'd like to thank you
[Applause]
is there any consequence of anything
like this to the actually natural
algorithm so that the slime model can't
I don't know coverage faster sorry can
you repeat your question we do anything
to the actual natural algorithm of the
slime model so that we can make the not
sure perhaps you'll have to go and do
the gene editing or you could edit the
genes to implement your algorithm that's
where you realize my simplicity of
algorithms is such a big constraint in
nature because in nature these
algorithms have to be passed from one
generation to another so you know
algorithms which are 70 page Long's
are unlikely to be transmitted from one
generation to another I think the other
way is probably more interesting to
analyze these algorithms when they work
fast yeah so there are you know this is
again an offline topic of discussion
there there are talk shows in Germany
which talk about things like this and
whether this whole universe whether this
whole universe is is inside a big slime
mold and I'm not joking but my answer is
I don't think so because you know the
the timescale of this video that I
showed you is not in real time it's it's
it's over several hours you know
I don't see that but I believe you yeah
I mean the way the sense in which it is
I would think of it as an interior point
method is that there is a there is a
Romanian metric which is guiding the
trajectories so there is the Hessian
inverse of the function right so here
it's a hessian inverse of some other
function which is the entropy functional
so in that sense there is a connection
there is also a disconnect at this
algorithm you can prove works no matter
where you start from you don't even have
to start more feasible point and this is
something I didn't emphasize in interior
point methods it's it's it's it's
usually difficult to ensure this I don't
know of a interior point method which no
matter where you start from it converges
to the optimal point
this one does we can prove that so you
don't have to start in the subspace if
you start from outside the subspace you
will still converge to an optimal point
corresponding to the to the subspace but
only from outside you will never enter
the never enter the subspace so that's
something very curious about this method
as well
no no so this would be feasible if your
initial point was feasible if you start
off with some something infeasible the
dynamic still makes sense and it
converges yes the connection is so if
you start with a point on that central
that that's or if you start to define
parameterize by that Miu yeah then the
continuous dynamics follow that path
exactly right that's right but that
interpretation holds only for a start
from inside the body if you start from
outside the body these dynamics still
make sense and actually provably
converge on the PI star on that yeah
yeah if you start on that path yeah
questions
[Applause]